[MUSIC]
Welcome, everybody, wherever you
are to this event sponsored by
the cooperation society initiative,
CASI at Stanford GSB.
My name is Anat Admati, and
I'm a faculty director of CASI.
With CASI we seek to engage
the broader community here and elsewhere.
On issues around governance, in business
and in government, which are essential for
our market system to
deliver on its promise.
We want powerful people and
institutions to be accountable to society.
I'm a professor of finance and today
is about finance and financial markets.
What does that have to do with CASI?
In our basic finance courses
which have taught for many years,
we assert that the stock wise embodies
all the great things corporations can do.
All the positive net present value
projects are basic teachings and
their motto is that most academic study,
assume away the possibility.
Have fraud and do not have hedge fund
investors who try to make money.
Finding fraud and betting on price
going down when they do find it,
but today we have that
counterexample right here.
We're so lucky to be able to host
Tammy Khadia who will explain in
further detail why her work is so
relevant for CASI.
And moderating this event and
introducing her father is one of our
amazing student leaders Crisco Baum.
Who actually is himself from
the financial sector and
going back to the financial sector.
So I'm sure it'll be
a fascinating discussion.
And thank you all to our
leaders on the Romanies
watching the chat,
the Q&A for your questions.
And thanks Loretta and the event team
at GSB for making this event possible.
I let Chris take it over from here,
thank you very much.
>> I thank you Anat and good afternoon to
everybody joining us here virtually today.
Glad to have you all here with us for
this very special session.
By way of introduction,
I am a second year MBA student here at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
And as Anat mentioned, I myself come
from the finance and investing world.
With four years at JPMorgan for
the business school and
joining Blackrock as an investment
professional on upon graduation.
So without further ado, I am honored to
introduce Fahmi Quadir our guest of honor.
Fahmi is the founder of the hedge fund
Stafkhet capital where she focuses on
concentrated short positions driven by
in depth investigation of fraud and
corporate crimes.
For those in the room who may not be
familiar with the term short selling is
when an investor like Fahmi borrows
shares of stock to sell today,
with the expectation that
the stock price will fall.
They will be able to buy those
shares back at a lower future price,
thereby pocketing the difference.
The potential losses
are theoretically infinite,
as there's no limit to how
high a stock price can go.
And in a bull market as we had the past
decade, stocks mostly tend to go up.
So Fahmi is here with us today to shed
a light on how she has persevered
through such an environment.
And our work keeps companies
accountable at the end of the day.
So Fahmi, we'd love to start off by
getting your take on the state of play
today know with rising inflation
increasing shocks to the market,
geopolitical tension.
Do you think we're in a materially
different spot from last year,
what does that mean?
>> So, thank you Chris and
thank you Anat and
thank you to the Stanford community and to
CASI for hosting me virtually this year.
I'm joining you all from London the latest
place that my work has taken me so
it's evening here.
And I'm hopeful that maybe next semester
I'll be able to join you guys on campus.
[LAUGH] So to start, I think there's
little that's more insufferable
than hearing single stock fundamental
investors talk economics.
So, [LAUGH] I'll do my best
to stay in my lane here.
For as long as I've been in business,
I've heard managers very publicly,
very boisterously complain about the FED,
about negative interest rates
that quantitative easing.
And they've always blamed all of this for
their under performance.
At the same time,
they've allowed this myth of the FED
put to become totally internalized.
It's a part of the collective
investment consciousness right now.
And this FED put has been used
to justify complete speculation,
I think most normal people
would call it gambling.
These are behaviors that a few years ago
at least from my seat were things that
would be dismissed as day trading but it's
now become accepted investing practice.
And we are seeing it especially
in liquid markets like crypto and
like within equities.
So this kind of gambling mentality has
almost become muscle memory for investors
who once upon a time may have considered
themselves fundamental investors.
So it's going to take a lot,
a lot for this investors to unlearn
some of this bad behaviors.
So even if the economic realities
that you are talking about, wages,
prices, UClean, even those we're
constantly exposed to these narratives,
it's not really sinking in.
Rather, it's sometimes what we see is
that the market is often driven by false
narratives.
And one thing that I started hearing a lot
starting at the end of last year was
that value is king and
that growth is dead.
Okay, I can understand why people
might say this at first because
of course we did see a sell off in the QQ
so the top 100 names in the NASDAQ.
So we saw a lot of the repricing and some
of these growth momentum driven names.
But at the same time,
what does value really mean?
I believe that markets are generally
pretty efficient, so if something
of company has been trading at a very
single digit multiple for many years.
I don't know if I would necessarily
call that cheap, it's probably garbage.
So, the thing that we
saw during the pandemic,
were a lot of businesses that were on
their last leg that we're reaching for
fraud for
example to extend their life-cycle.
Suddenly had extra liquidity that
was completely unexpected, and
over that period they were
able to buy additional time.
Or buy additional time to continue
to defraud people for example.
So we saw a lot of use these
consumer finance businesses for
example we like to look at payday lenders.
All of them got a new lease on life
because of all this liquidity, but
the thing is these things were
always trading below book value.
They were always trading as cheap
businesses on if you look at multiples.
Why is that?
[LAUGH] it's because these businesses
are a dependent on screwing
over their customer.
So over time the business model
blows up especially when you're
entering a tightening
cycle as far as credit.
So this is one of the false
narratives that I've seen pop up in
the past few months.
Where people are considering only that
a business is generating cash but
not the quality of that cash flow
which should be equally as important.
But another thing that I'm hearing
a lot is that someone is so stuck.
Is now down 50%, so
the bottom is in by the dip.
So what that tells me is that even
though the headlines are showing
that we're all a lot more uncertain
about what the future looks like,
people are still using share
price as a determining factor for
their various investment decisions.
They're call on whether a business
is going to grow or fail.
It's, again, still driven by price,
driven by momentum.
So while some investors are starting
to get their mojo back,
thinking that maybe we're
getting back to fundamentals.
As someone who's sort of been
watching this play out, and
is hyper exposed to prices that
are disconnected from fundamentals,
as much as I'd like to say that we're
getting there, I don't know if we have.
We're not there yet.
Again, we're trying to use this
false fundamental sprinkling of
a narrative on top of something
that still hasn't changed,
which is prices being
driven by these narratives.
And sometimes these false narratives
is driven by sentiment and
momentum, not by real analysis.
So while it seems hopeful, and
if you just look at how the portfolio
has performed over the last six
months compared to the past year,
obviously, things seem like
they've gotten better.
But it's never really satisfying when
things are moving for reasons other
than the various pieces of information
we've picked out in our analysis.
>> So it's interesting Fahmi that you
mention this huge focus on narrative
over analysis kind of
taking prevalence and
determining how people are deciding
what to invest in the market today.
And I think if you look back to last year,
there's maybe no narrative that got
more press than the GameStop saga.
So I think one question that's on
our audience minds is what is your
understanding of what happened there?
>> I don't know [LAUGH].
I get asked about this a lot.
But I think at base, while the media
is trying to create like a David,
Goliath story, or talking about hedge
funds taking on excessive leverage,
you're taking on these ridiculous bets.
That stuff has always existed.
Retail Investors have also always existed.
They become more prevalent, and
they're more part of our focus as
a society in the peak of the bull market,
right?
Because that's when people
start seeing advertisements for
crypto while they're
watching the Superbowl.
And then grandma might be
watching the Superbowl and
saying I'm not making any money
holding my cash in the bank.
Why don't I get into those high
yield crypto savings accounts?
So we're at that point in the cycle where
you kind of have this strange tension,
where clearly things are maybe going to
not be as good as they've been, right?
We clearly had the pandemic, and
that has covered up a lot of bad behavior
in some of the businesses
that we look like.
It provided liquidity to businesses
that probably shouldn't have had it.
But now we're going to see what is
the consequence of all of that?
Have we seen peak growth
at least in the near term?
And what does that mean for
businesses that were simply not growing,
or were simply losing money for
the past decades?
So as much as it feels
as though certain stocks
have had these violent moves, in reality,
I would say most people
are as bullish as ever.
And there's a danger to this,
because it's this mentality
that this idea that
the stock market can never go down 50% or
80%,
because it's almost like
an apocalyptic sort of situation.
People can't fathom the idea that prices
may correct, and multiples may change.
And the way the economy has been growing,
it might slow down.
It's like we've been trying
to delude ourselves into
thinking this time is different.
But it's rarely ever different, including
these situations like GameStop and
AMC, and the rise of the retail trader.
It always happens.
It's really just everyone is going to
try to enjoy the party while it lasts,
but who's going to be
the last one to leave?
>> So I suppose with that focus
then on sort of narrative, and
the rational factors taking a backseat,
that tends to drown out sort of
the strength of a well
reasoned investment thesis.
And I'm wondering then does that change
how you think about the role that you play
in the market?
>> It's really, really difficult.
I can't understate how difficult it is.
The guys that I went to for advice,
that I looked up to when I
was starting Softcat and
figuring out how do I get a short
only fund up and running?
Those guys were retiring, and
not because they're old, but
simply because it's intolerable.
The losses that short sellers have
had to suffer have been intolerable.
But it's not just that, it's sort of
this cycle where yes, the losses are bad
because the markets are going up,
because there's a lot of liquidity, and
because fundamentals have become
much more disconnected from price.
But that also feeds into
the capital allocation cycle,
where allocators are looking
at short sellers and
saying why am I going to pay
to be hedged in this market?
I'll just lose money.
So there hasn't been much allocating
activity to short focus funds,
so that has pushed us to
the brink of extinction.
And it's just you can only tolerate so
much, right, as far as losses,
as far as willing to tolerate
those losses in the market.
So many short sellers have just tried to
figure out different ways of doing things.
And everyone's heard
the phrase your bull market
dies when the last bear capitulates.
So I think that statement's
a little bit archaic,
because maybe in prior market cycles,
there were no bears like
me who have the pain tolerance
to continue doing this.
Because throughout this entire period,
we've remained short only, and
we've always remained exposed
to that risk in the market.
And yeah, it's certainly not easy.
I understand why people
don't want to do it.
But when the clearing moments happens
in the market, whenever that is,
whatever that looks like, it's people
like me that come to pick up the pieces,
because we've already done the work.
We understand these businesses, so
we can help provide signals for
what's the most effective and
the safest ways to allocate capital in
that new market order, whenever it comes.
So perhaps, let's maybe shift gears a
little bit because I think there's another
topic that also tends to come
up a lot here at Stanford.
And that's the increasing importance of
private markets as a conduit of capital
to the growing companies of today.
So you now have this growing space where
you don't have the ability to maybe easily
bet against these companies.
How do you hold them accountable if most
of the capital being raised is now in
a space where it's not easy to
put on a position against them?
>> So I'm glad I'm not there in person for
this question because I think I would
have had some tomatoes thrown at me.
But I'd just like to ask you,
do private investors need protecting?
Because I would say in most cases,
public markets need to be protected
from private investor exits.
These private equity and VC dudes,
they're not stupid, they are stupid rich.
So in most cases in my experience,
these investors know exactly
whether the technology or
idea they're investing in is something
that's even remotely plausible.
More often than not, they just don't care.
[LAUGH] They'll happily invest in these
non-ideas that are completely fantastical.
Because let's see, they get in these
businesses at ridiculous terms.
Their investors give them more money to
do it and they'll pay them higher fees.
So if you want to keep
getting more stupid rich,
you need to invest in more stupider and
stupider businesses.
Because as long as the equity markets are
preaching, buy the dip, look at that TAM,
diamond hands, then private equity
investors will get their exit.
So [LAUGH] what we've seen
over the past decade is
that hedge fund managers
are looking at all of this and
saying hey, we can't make money
in public markets anymore.
So we're going to do that too.
And it's just been toxic.
Its toxic for public markets because
the pension funds, the retail investors
who get duped into buying this trash,
they're the ones who are holding the bag.
But it's also toxic for
the businesses themselves.
I think a very good example of some,
the toxic elements of this is what
you see happening in Tel Aviv.
It's become now,
it's the most expensive city in the world.
SoftBank has opened an office there.
You have millions that are being thrown at
very smart young people who don't have any
idea what they're going to build, or
what they're going to do with that money.
And just ignoring the businesses
that might have come public,
that might be sort of fraudy.
There are startups that are good
ideas that are run by good people,
that deserve a chance at
growing their business,
that are being prematurely forced
to go public through SPACs.
Because and often times at absurd
valuations that the founders
never ever would have imagined,
and will never accept,
except their VC backers
are egging them on to do it.
So they're now entering public markets
when they're totally not prepared for it.
So to me,
this is literally value destruction.
It is not innovation.
It's like the opposite side of
vulture capitalism, [LAUGH] but
it's equally damaging.
So how do we solve this problem?
Again, comes down to allocators,
allocators continuously pump
money into private equity funds,
into venture capital.
They hold the bag so
they should do more to hold these various
firms accountable, and
that's I think the place to start.
>> So I guess maybe what
follows from that then is,
as a GP who's had
conversations with allocators,
what question do you think they
ought to be asking that they aren't?
That would help them maybe
figure out who's for real,
and who's just chasing the latest trend?
>> Well, they really should be thinking
about what is the real thesis
behind this investment?
Is my manager providing some
kind of story that isn't even
a solid story that they're using just
as like a veneer to cover up what
they know is a guaranteed
money-making venture?
The thing is with these
sorts of situations,
regulators are watching,
politicians are watching.
Increasingly, private equity
venture capital is no longer
the darling innovation
driving Silicon Valley.
People are starting to call out the fees,
call out the way that they actually
measure their performance.
They're calling out the effect that
they're having on these new developing
businesses.
So before someone's hand is forced,
allocators should really
be more thoughtful and
put more pressure on having these firms
actually explain what the business is.
What is the plan for that business?
And what is a realistic exit so
that those businesses will not just
collapse after the venture
backing has been pulled?
>> And so I think kind of branching
off of that, there's maybe,
there's the allocator angle to look at and
then perhaps the regulator angle as well.
And I think one question that's been
raised a little bit now is how the recent
SEC focus on SPAC accounting.
Restatements is going to
impact some of that behaviour.
And sort of what's your take on that?
>> I think it should have happened sooner.
[LAUGH] It should have happened sooner.
Because think about how many SPACs came
to market before the SEC came out and
said that we need to take a look at the
disclosure requirements for these SPACs.
We're always slow to the ball.
Fraudsters are always way, fraudsters and
greedy people are always going to
be many steps ahead of us.
So I would think that given
the scrutiny that the SEC is now
focusing upon SPACs and
just the risks involved and
the fact that SPACs are wildly
underperforming in the market right now.
I think businesses, business
founders will give some more thought
to just going along with what
their VC partners are saying.
And they'll probably hold off on
trying to come to market through SPAC.
And we are actually seeing
this happen more where these
mergers just blow up,
so that's a good thing.
But the companies that are still pursuing
the SPACs are at this point in the cycle,
I think are guaranteed to be garbage for
the most part.
That's at least from what I've seen.
>> And I think that's a sentiment that's
being echoed in a lot of places where
the flow of SPAC capital was all but
dried up in more recent months.
So I think maybe we can
shift gears a little bit,
maybe talk about some of the ins and
outs of what you do as a short seller.
I think one of the biggest challenges
that we hear about from the outside is
that a lot of the executive teams,
management teams who you are interested
in hearing from Once they know that
you're taking the short position,
they know who you are,
they don't want to talk to you.
How do you get the ear of somebody
who's kind of predisposed to
see you as the bad guy?
>> Well, I try first and foremost,
to operate in a way that
is completely unassailable.
So if the company's management was to
reject me, to look at me in the wrong way,
to try and do something,
it should for the most part,
make them look unreasonable and
make them look guilty.
So even if the management itself
may view me as their adversary,
I have been to events for example,
where are the shareholders
of the company know who I am and
hold me in some regard.
So if the company's executives
try to be hostile towards
me in those in person events,
shareholders have intervened
on my behalf because they
understand that I'm not there
to cause a scene,
I'm not there to create any drama.
I'm just there to observe and
I'm there to engage
just as any other market
participant would.
So in general, in general I have a good
track record of being able to sit down
with management because just frankly
it's easier for them to do that.
Because maybe there's a small chance
they can convince me that everything I'm
asking about I'm just
completely misguided.
So far hasn't happened [LAUGH] but
still they can at least try.
But it's interesting because you often
hear other short sellers say that they
don't speak to management because they
don't want to be seduced by the lies.
I would like to tell you all that
I think that is complete BS,
because if there's any very solidly,
consistently,
BS detectors in the market,
they're short sellers.
They're deeply cynical.
It's going to be very hard for
any even the most charismatic of
management to ever be convincing
them of any sort of lie.
So I would think that most of the time
other short sellers say this,
because they don't get the same
opportunity to meet with management
because they operate in a different way.
So they might have a much
more public presence,
they might be publishing reports,
they might be frequently talking about
the company on Twitter and like live
tweeting, meeting with management.
So I stay away from all of that
because I see the value in
actually being able to sit down and
have those discussions.
If nothing else, if there's nothing
informational, it's really about,
sometimes the softer things and being able
to assess behavior in those meetings and
establish a baseline.
How stressed is this executive?
How much is he sweating
in these situations?
So I hope that through this, I'm able to
just sort of normalize having discussions,
for company management to sit down
with those who have critical views and
probing questions just as they
would with any analyst who wants to
congratulate them on good earnings.
It should be just a sign
of a healthy market, and
the strength really of
the business itself.
>> Yeah, I think one of
the biggest examples that and
I talked about it in the lead up to
this talk was your work on Wirecard.
And sort of the how you were
able to get inside the tent and
figure out what was really going on.
So I think it would be great if you could
talk about that maybe a little bit.
>> Yeah, so criticism of Wirecard
began the day there was the Wirecard.
And it didn't start with short sellers, it
started with Wirecard's own shareholders.
This was a business that was focused on
processing payments in the early days for
online pornography, and
that's literally all it was.
And in some ways,
that's literally all it ever was, if there
was any legitimate part of Wirecards
business it was that it did it process for
porn and process for
offshore gaming, things like this.
This sort of gray market of
ecommerce Wirecard was there.
So, yes,
that was the legitimate piece of Wirecard.
But the thing with these
types of businesses,
businesses that are focused on
facilitating transactions in the gray
market digitally,
they're doomed to failure.
So by and large they never go public,
because they don't want the scrutiny.
And they never get very large.
And that's just because they're limited by
just the economics of the business model.
Because the more you have transactions
that are in these sketchy areas,
the more likely that
a consumer will allege fraud.
And if there's potential fraud and
the bank that issued that credit
card agrees with the consumer,
then you're on the hook.
And then you have to,
the fees start to add up.
And eventually what happens is you
get kicked off the card networks.
So this is, in a nutshell
what Wirecard's business was.
Yet somehow Wirecard managed to
become a $20 billion company.
It managed to send those shareholders
that ask those probing questions to jail.
[LAUGH] And it also managed to time and
time again, completely just brush
aside short seller allegations.
And this last round of criticism against
Wirecard, it also tried to brush off.
So let's go back a few years to 2017.
So at this time in 2017,
a lot of things were happening,
especially within the payments space.
If you don't know already Wirecard,
now people are admitting
it was basically a front for
global money laundering.
What you see happening in 2017
is that a lot of the business,
a lot of that laundering
business that was flowing through
Wirecard is finding a home in crypto and
in digital assets.
And we actually see a lot of the
individuals that were bringing business
to Wirecard now starting
crypto businesses instead.
So Wirecard was fundamentally under
pressure because the whole thing was
kept alive because they had
tremendous volume coming from that
money laundering business.
So what happens next?
Germany decides Wirecard is one of
the best companies in our country,
so we are going to include
them in the the DAX.
So DAX think of like the German
version of a Dow Jones.
So it's like the top, most solidly
blue chip companies in Germany and
they we're going to include Wirecard.
At the same time,
a whistleblower who worked for
Wirecard in Asia came forward with fraud,
fake contracts that he saw in.
Wirecard Asia, and
he then took that information and
went to the Financial Times.
And the Financial Times started
publishing, on Wirecard.
So what was Wirecard response?
Fake News?
Financial Times is criminal.
It's colluding with short sellers.
And what is the German securities
regulator say when one of the best
financial news outlets decides to publish
all this critical work on this business.
The German securities
regulator Boffin comes out and
says we're going to investigate
the Financial Times for
market manipulation, so, [LAUGH]
A few months later what happens next?
Why are cars stock after getting
the DAX The stock price doesn't seem
to go up anymore.
This is a problem and also,
the stock price also seems to go down when
the Financial Times publishes reports.
So what does the German securities
regulator decide to do?
They say we're going to ban
short selling in Wirecard.
[LAUGH] So this was just an incredible
moment and I was actually at CASI for
the first time within days of this
announcement and it was the first time
you've ever seen this in any developed
market where a single security that
isn't systemically important have short
selling ban it was absolutely insane.
So we knew at that point despite our
efforts to get Boffin on board with
our analysis that they
weren't going to do anything.
So as a short seller it's really important
for us to focus on who is going to care
about the information that we have and our
research was focused on money laundering.
And money laundering matters to no
one more than the United States.
So that was our angle.
So we dug in deep.
We tried to figure out everything
Wirecard was doing in the US.
We tried to figure out all the actors
involved who was the kingpin of
that business.
And we try to get as much confidence
around that information tied up
neatly in a bow and
give it to authorities.
So that they could do that, the next
steps which would mean subpoenas so
this eventually led to march 2020 where
the kingpin of the US
business was arrested.
And another a German former
Wirecard guy was also arrested.
And this was again before
anyone really knew what was
happening because no one was following
the US and what was happening here.
But Wirecard's co founder, the supposed
Russian agent, Yan Morris he was,
of course following what was happening,
I mean this US guy who was
arrested with his best friend.
So it was the second week of March,
it was at Yan Morris 40th birthday
party he had a complete mental breakdown,
he drank two bottles of vodka by himself,
rolling around the ground crying,
you know mumbling to himself.
And two months later Wirecard
of course collapsed because
that man Jan Morris was gone,
$2 billion were gone, and
seller, I had just covered my Wirecard,
my last few shares that I had short.
It was about two weeks ago,
because it was finally
delisted officially, so
I'm no longer in the trade.
>> I guess that's a phase where the book
is finally closed on the Wirecard.
I know that you put out a paper on your
funds on your firm's website basically
explaining your response to Bothans
decision and sort of a argument for
your role as the short seller
in keeping the market honest.
And I think I'm kind of curious,
what was Boffins response to that paper?
Were they receptive to your argument?
>> Well, they didn't ignore me.
Before I published the letter, of course,
I gave Boffin a chance to respond to me,
and sit down with me.
What did they say they said no they
said no they didn't ignore my emails and
ignore my letter they read my letter but
they said no.
I reached out to them again after that I
have information I have analysis that I
feel you should know about Wirecard and
they were like No, not interested.
I was in Frankfort speaking
at a legal conference, and
I was outside of Boffins offices.
I called them I said I'm here.
I'm outside your door.
Can we meet, they said no.
[LAUGH] So, just like I said,
I have this information that I tied up,
put it on a silver platter tied it up and
both had to they were not interested.
So we had to find the authorities that
were interested in that information.
>> You kind of have yourself in this
position where you really have to go over
their heads for
somebody to start paying attention to it.
>> Yeah!
I never want to do that,
it's a German company, right?
They are the domestic
regulator like I said,
I don't like to create drama, so
I didn't want this to happen.
I gave them every chance in the world, but
it wasn't even like I wasn't
getting through to them.
It's just that they were just saying no,
they wanted nothing to do with me.
>> Perhaps it's an issue of alignment of
interests if it's your country's darling
company that's driving your stock market
you maybe don't want to be the person who
allows people to put in
that's against them.
>> Well yeah because Germany is largely,
it's an industrial
manufacturer type of economy, so
this was a technology company or
at least it was able to go
around parading itself as so.
So it was within German interest
to of course promote that,
even if they didn't necessarily know
the criminal extent of the behaviors.
That said,
perhaps between the US and Germany,
there's a misalignment of
geopolitical interests here.
Because the US, of course, is a lot
more interested in money laundering.
They're a lot more interested in
going up against these sanctions
on Russian oligarchs.
That is something that is
a geopolitical interest for
us also because we
are the world's fiat currency.
So we do need to worry about the integrity
of the dollar and of US financial system.
So money laundering is a big deal for
us, Germany [LAUGH] It's a dime a dozen.
How many money laundering
scandals have been there?
And I don't think this means that
no we can just say Germany is
a money laundering haven but
it's just not a priority for
them naturally just as much as trying
to diversify their economy, maybe.
>> It's interesting that,
he fast forward to today and
we look at what's going on in
Ukraine with the prices with Russia.
One of the potential, I guess,
penalties that has been talked about,
is limiting or
cutting off access to the SWIFT system.
And so there are rumblings that Russia and
China are looking to create
an international payment system.
What does that do if suddenly you have
a section of global economy that is cut
off from us control and
influence that's sort of a check and
balance she's removed
>> Well just it's so
interesting though that we're at
this moment because all of Scholtz
the new chancellor of Germany
was in charge you know right
Overseeing financial
regulations under Merkel.
And that was during the Wirecard scandal.
So he was in charge of overseeing
Boffin during that whole period.
And that isn't to say that he
was guilty of anything, but
it is just a severe lack of oversight.
[LAUGH] So I think it's all very
interesting to see how this
has all been playing out politically.
But we already have an economy
that exists outside
of the financial market that the US
oversees and regulates, right?
The thing is, these criminals,
organized crime,
have found a way to make that
market bigger and more liquid and
more convenient for
them through innovation.
And the government,
just as it is with with most things,
is very slow on the innovation side.
And it's going to be a really
hard game of catching
up now to all of these
new innovations in DeFi,
Web3, all of these things,
while it's like these
criminals are printing money.
[LAUGH] That's effectively what it is.
So rogue states, more oppressive regimes,
they might see a benefit in
aligning themselves with these
criminal interests because it suits some
of their own national priorities, right?
So it's going to be difficult, but I think
we need to act sooner rather than later.
And this isn't to say that
we cut them out of SWIFT.
I think it's probably more difficult and
not as practical of a thing.
I'm not sure how it would work,
but just thinking about
where is the dark money,
how is that currently existing?
That economy, how do we do
a better job of regulating it?
Or at least integrating
our own economic system,
our own financial systems,
in a more cohesive sort of way.
>> Right, I guess, it's how do we get a
handle on these flows of payments where as
with many other things, technology
seems to move a mile a minute, and
government regulation can hardly
keep up with the pace of change.
>> Yeah, but
human beings are also prone to failure.
I'm sure everyone has read
about the great Bitcoin heist.
How did they eventually get caught?
It was because they put
money onto a prepaid card.
And that's also kind of
what led us to Wirecard.
Because eventually, you will need to
be able to use cash, and prepaid cards,
they're very old school but
they're also still very convenient.
But these are little things,
prepaid cards are not a new innovation.
And ultimately, people who
are needing to have clean money,
they sometimes want actual cash.
So if they need to use a prepaid card for
that, then maybe
we need to start thinking about why do we
have prepaid cards in the first place.
>> Right, exactly.
So I think, as we're thinking about
situations like Wirecard, you've
got a couple different players who are
expected to sort of keep everybody honest.
You've got the government,
you've got the investors such as yourself,
who are looking at the company and
trying to ferret out what's going wrong.
And of course, you've got the auditors
who are supposed to vet the financial
statements for accuracy.
I think one question that kind of
pops up as we look at a situation is,
why wouldn't the auditors have identified
these items perhaps before short-sellers
would have caught on to them, given that
they were essentially responsible for
ensuring these were accurately presented?
>> Wirecard, I think,
is a unique situation.
It is a very clear example of what we
would call an overly cozy relationship
between the auditing partners and
their client, Wirecard in this case.
When you're auditing someone for
such a long period of time, you start
asking fewer and fewer questions, or
you take certain things at face value.
So I think we have to consider what is
the right period of time that an auditor
should be auditing a particular business
and balancing their expertise and
familiarity of the financial statements
with the fact that they are so
closely working with the same client for
many years.
So that's one issue.
But we can't just depend on one piece,
one stakeholder within this
ecosystem to find everything,
because auditors can get screwed over,
too.
Because, when we're talking about frauds,
when we're talking about businesses
criminal management, sociopathic
management, they're going to lie and
say whatever they need to, create whatever
fake documentation that they need to,
to defraud that the auditors as well.
So we can't forget that piece.
So there needs to be multiple checks and
balances here because it's
not as though short-sellers
are the first line of defense in fraud.
We're basically one of the last
lines of defense against fraud.
So yeah, I can't just put all
the blame on the auditors.
And at the end of the day,
auditors are hired by the company itself.
And they're not there to find fraud,
they're there to just ensure
all the boxes are checked,
that the books are balanced, and
that's really the crux of their job.
What I don't think auditors,
maybe they could perhaps spend
more time assessing some
of the softer features and
more governance-related features within
a business, like tone at the top.
I think it's really important to
understand the culture of the place
because fraud doesn't occur in a vacuum.
There's usually opportunities,
incentives that exist there for
someone to potentially put
their livelihood on the line to
commit fraud that will
enrich the business.
So yeah, there are small
things that can be done, but
even still,
it'll never end with just the auditors.
I think every piece of
this is equally important.
>> I think that tone from the top
piece is really one that does or
ought to resonate heavily with
the people on this call who
are from the Stanford Business School and
other business school classes,
who may well be going on to these sorts
of leadership positions at some point
in our career and will be in
the position to set that sort of a tone.
And basically,
it's that the trouble begins long before
it gets to deciding which numbers to
adjust or which figures to fudge.
It really starts with how
people think about right and
wrong from the culture of the company,
it sounds like.
>> Yes, exactly, and
sometimes it's just as practical as,
what can you get away with?
Because not everyone is going to have
the most sterling moral compass.
So with Wirecard, for example,
They were literally taking plastic
bags full of cash to and
from Wirecard headquarters, right?
And Wirecard employees, everyone
this is in full, plain sight, right?
So if I'm some middle manager in Asia and
I hear that this is going on and
I realize that I can be as
aggressive as possible, and
I'll still have a job, and
I'll actually be rewarded by the business.
>> My God, that sounds like something out
of a movie when you describe it that way.
It's like a scene from Wolf of
Wall Street, I don't know [LAUGH].
>> It's worse, it's even worse.
>> So I guess as we're getting down
to some of our final questions here,
I think one other item that
comes up from our audience,
within the GameStop saga of last year.
And sort of this narrative-driven
short selling and short squeezing.
Melvin Capital almost went under because
of their short position on GameStop.
And I think there was another fund that
made money on the opposite side of that
trade going long.
And I think that the question that comes
up a lot from retail investors and
people who are kind of watching the market
is might there have been any sort of
manipulation that had been going on?
Are there bad actors, perhaps who are
getting involved in the midst of all this.
>> There are bad actors everywhere.
There are bad actors regardless
of market conditions.
And I think,
just the difficulty of generating alpha in
these markets have probably
forced some managers,
who previously were not overly aggressive
or taking excessive leverage or
engage in any kind of
dubious market activity.
Perhaps they felt the pressure
too just because it's so
hard to prove yourself to your investors.
Or it's hard to keep your track
record going because once you start
making a lot of money, people
are going to continually expect you to.
Whether around GameStop,
there was a manipulation,
I mean, it's beyond my expertise,
I have no idea.
As a portfolio manager,
would I ever put myself in a position
where in a single stock bet, long or
short, my business can go under.
I would never do that, but
that's me and I'm a short seller with
a perverse relationship with risk and
I'm saying this, so yeah.
I don't understand why a PM would
let their book get to that point.
But things happen,
funds blow up, people move on.
It's not necessarily conspiracy,
it's the jungle.
[LAUGH] This is how it goes.
>> It's just the nature of
playing the game so to speak.
>> Well, that's the thing.
This market has been all about
playing games and not about thinking.
>> So I think, as we're sort of getting
down to the end of our time here.
I'm just kind of curious to hear a little
bit more about what it's like to be
fun in career and sort of what does
the best day in your life look like?
And maybe,
what does the worst day look like?
>> Yeah, the best days are the ones
where that nagging question that I have,
that I've been obsessing over for like
a year, I'm finally able to answer it.
However that may be.
And those days are only
rivaled by the days when I
finally see my thesis
materializing before me.
When a company comes out during their
earnings and totally kitchen sinks it.
And when authorities come out and
say that they've made arrests of
key figures that I suspected were
engaged in criminal activity.
Or it's when the FTC sends a cease and
desist order to a business that we
believe was preying on consumers.
So when things like that happen,
those are the most satisfying.
Those are the most rewarding days.
The worst days [LAUGH] are days
like this one, believe it or not.
It's just days where
the markets are bleeding.
Where the market's sell off broadly,
violently, because they make my
job as a PM very difficult, because
I can't rely on my trusted toolkit.
I can't just look at my thesis,
I can't look at my information,
my analysis, my research.
I have to start making decisions based on
things that to me feel more speculative.
So basically,
how much further down can something go?
And how much risk I'm I
willing to leave on the table?
So every day, I think that,
I incrementally get better at this and
there's no better test than
the one the market we've been in.
But it's really hard,
as someone who's so research driven.
If fundamental factors remain unchanged,
justifying why I
should change my positioning,
[LAUGH] it's very difficult.
>> So
how does a day like that typically unfold?
What's going through your head [LAUGH]?
>> I guess I do talk to CASI because I
feel like every time I've done a CASI
talk, it's been a bleeding
day in the markets.
So yeah, I just,
I don't try to get too reflexive.
I just take a step back,
focus on my research.
And get a good night's rest and then
decide what I'm going to do the next day,
no one's going to die [LAUGH].
>> What about some of these things like
this New York times article that came out
recently.
Where I think you mentioned that,
I think your printer turned on one night
and started printing out whistleblower
letters-
>> Yeah.
>> Just on its own without
any input from you and
that was almost like somebody hacked
in and they knew how to get at you.
>> Yeah, we deal with this kind of stuff
all the time, it's like a running joke.
Whenever something bad happens,
we'll attribute it to Wirecard or
some other criminal interest that
we might be on the wrong side of.
But you get used to it.
I think in some ways, I've learned
to embrace it because it's probably
validation that we're on the right
track with whatever we're doing.
So it never gives me pause.
When I got into this business, of course,
I knew it was going to be a dangerous
business, that I know how
dangerous it could get.
Absolutely not.
But one of the main learnings is that
you can never be paranoid enough.
So I'm always cautious.
I'm always observant.
But now, I'm in London, right?
There was a time when I was nervous,
maybe I couldn't do this kind of
work in London, but now I'm all in.
[LAUGH] So I think here,
London is one of those places,
parts of the city are basically
owned by Russian oligarchs.
It's a very interesting experience.
So it's an adrenaline rush
to be in the lion's den.
>> I mean, did you feel like London is
sort of, I guess, the best place to be and
to have a bird's eye view across all the
global markets rather than the US-centric,
perhaps you might get in New York.
>> Yes, exactly, you're basically smack
down in the middle and it's a gateway.
Right for
all of the money laundering activity,
London is the gateway
to the United States.
And I think that it's really
fascinating to see play out because
in some ways you know how Miami
could be considered the gateway for
Latin America to get to the US.
London is the same for
all of Europe and also Asia.
So it's a really great place to be.
This is the birthplace of a lot
of FinTech businesses, so
I get to see it all happen firsthand.
>> So, I think you've got a couple minutes
left here and I think what could be
interesting to talk about is, is there
anything that you're seeing lately
that perhaps you're not getting asked
about as much as you wish that you were?
>> About anything?
Honestly, people don't really
seem very concerned whether or
not there's actually deep levels of
fraud and criminality at any business.
That's the thing very broadly no
one wants to get in the weeds.
No one wants the expert view.
Everyone wants like the one liner.
They want very superficial analysis,
very one dimensional analysis.
No one really wants to hear
about all the work that
goes into the businesses
that were researching.
I think also because they don't care.
And people will only care after
sentiment in the market shifts and
we haven't gotten to that point yet.
>> Do you think that that's going to
change in a year's time perhaps if things
get tougher or is this just how things are
set to be just is it just human nature?
>> Yeah, I mean cycles will
play out as they play out and
some people will get lucky and
calling it the right way.
I think we all know how this ends,
I just I have no idea when that happens.
But it doesn't really matter for the
strategy because we're just always short,
we're always mostly 100%
short the markets through
the various companies that
we're betting against.
So, whether there's mass calamity,
market apocalypse,
whatever it may be, we are just here
being patient, continuing to do
the old school old fashioned kind of
work that we've always been doing.
>> It's true scuttle but
diligence and really digging in.
>> Exactly.
>> I want to thank you.
Thank you so much for joining us for me
and for everybody who has been on the line
with us, and hope everyone has
a great rest of their day.
[MUSIC]